Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Arkeoloji hayatı anlamaya çalışıyor.
Ama bugün kâğıdın yetmezliğini
bilerek geçmişin binlerce yılına bakıp,
oradaki milyonlarca örnekle
her bir konuyu anlamaya çalışıyor.
Anladık mı? Ama hiç anlamadık.
Ben yüz yaşına gelen bir profesör olarak
arkeolojinin içinde cebelleşen
yüzlerce kazı yapan birisi olarak
hala anlamadım.
Her önümüze gelen en küçük objede
birkaç bin yıl daha geriye gidip,
bir şeyi daha, biraz daha anlamanın
verdiği heyecanla
ama her an anladığımız, eksik anlamanın
eksikliğini anladığımız o anlarda,
biliyorum ki, hiçbir şeyi biz anlamadık.
Bugün yine hayatı sorguluyoruz bu salonda.
Bugün ve ben sorgularken de eğlenmeye
geldim sizle, topu size atıp gideceğim
en sonunda zaten.
Bu çünkü bizim belki de kifayet etmiyor,
becerimiz bunu anlamaya.
Ve hayatı, hayatın yavaşlığını ve
uzunluğunu da anlamaya çalışacağız ya.
İyi de, yavaş ve hız; birbirinin tam
tersi iki kavram.
Ama bu zıt kutuplar olmadan
zaten bir şey çalışmıyor ki.
Ak ve kara gibi bir şey bu.
Yani birisini silerseniz olmaz ki.
Gri mi olacak? Oda olmayacak, demek ki
ikisini tamamlamak zorundayız zaten.
Yavaş ve hızlının da kendilerine
göre erdemleri var.
Kendilerine göre güzellikleri var,
iyilikleri var, çekicilikleri var.
Ama birinden birini yok edeceğimiz
bir şey değil bu bence.
Ve hayat zaten bize
bunu böyle göstermemiş.
On binlerce yılın uygarlık tarihi bize
bunu böyle göstermiyor ki.
İşte bu size gösterdiğim slaytlarda bakın,
kendimizi biz bugün öyle bir bağlamışız ki
randevu defterlerine, kolumuzdaki saatlere
işte bilmem sosyal medyadaki
envayı türlü, Instagramlar,
Facebooklar, Twitterlar vesaireler,
binlerce şey cebimizde duruyor.
Dünya bizi işgal etmiş durumda duruyorlar.
Yemek bile düşünün ki siz gidip
öğle yemeği yediniz,
iyi de böyle bir şey tanımlanmamış ki.
Sabah kahvaltı yapacaksın,
öğlen yemek yiyeceksin,
akşam bir daha yemek yiyeceksin,
sonra yemeyeceksin ve uyuyacaksın.
Üç kere yemek yiyeceksin, bu kural yok ki.
Milyonlarca yıl yaşayan antropolojik
tarihimizde, bırakın uygarlık tarihini,
atalarımızın hiçbiri kendini böyle
planlamadı ki, sabah yemek yiyeceğim,
saat on iki oldu öğlen
bir daha yiyeceğim, hayır...
Normal doğadaki diğer canlılar gibi
acıktığında yedi,
acıkmadığında devam etti hayatına,
başka bir şey yapmaya.
Ne bulduysa onu yaptı o zamanlarda ve
bu kadardı ve biz bugün;
bunların hepsini planlamışısız ve
kendimizi böyle makinaymış gibi planlayıp
yani bir zaman geçtikçe,
geçmiş yığınlardan uzaklaştıkça,
belki makineye çevirmişiz kendimizi.
Mesela ben sizin karşınıza
elbiseyle çıkıyorum;
iyi de milyonlarca yıl benim atalarımın
hiçbiri elbise giymedi,
ki lazımda değildi doğada.
Nasıl doğduysa öylede öldü.
Şimdi bu insanın kendini
biçimlendirmesiyle ilgili bir şey.
Yani uygarlık tarihi ilerliyor ve
biz kendimizi bir şeye benzete benzete
devam ediyoruz.
Bir gün, bence denemek lazım, ben onu
epey bir denedim konsantre olup,
yani elektriksiz bütün elektriği
kapattığınız anda zaten
neolitik zamandasınız.
Bu yeter; yani elektriği kapattığınız anda
internet çalışmıyor, hiçbir şey çalışmıyor
hiçbir şey yok çalışmıyor hiçbir alet.
Ve lambalar kapalı, o zaman
başka bir gün yaşayacaksınız.
Evinizde bir gün kapatın ışıkları,
elektrik gittiği günler çok mutlu
olduğunuzu hatırlayın birde.
Çoluk çocuğunuzla, ailenizle eşinizle,
dostunuzla bir tane mum yakıp,
ne derin sohbetlere
daldınız elektriği beklerken.
Geldiği anda her şey birden bitiyor.
Yani aydınlık geliyor güya ama,
karanlık geliyor beraberinde.
Bir anda defterden vesaireden
kurtulduğumuz zaman herhalde
anlayacağız ki biz bu hayatın özünü.
Peki arkeoloji ne diyor buna?
Yani arkeoloji içerisinde on binlerce yıl,
binlerce farklı kültür, her,
tarihin derinliğindeki her bir noktada
komşuluk ilişkileri de birbirinden
farklılaşan binlerce farklı kültür,
başka bir şey söylüyor bize.
Her birisi, çünkü kendi
kültürüyle yaşıyor.
Her insan nasıl ki kendi karakteriyle
yaşıyorsa oda kendi kültürüyle yaşıyor.
Yani birimize göre iyi olan bir şey
öbürüne göre kötü ki.
Birinize göre ayıp olan bir şey,
öbürüne göre ayıp değil.
Ya da bir zamanlar ayıp olan bir şey,
bugün ayıp değil,
yarın başka bir şey olacak
tekrar ayıp olacak falan.
Bunu, biz toplumlar
kültürlerimizi yansıtıyoruz.
Biz kültür biliminde bunları tanımlarken
çok da zorlanıyoruz. Yani bu kültür iyi de
bu kötüde, bunda çok yasak var.
Hayır onun formu o diye devam ederiz.
Arkeoloji çok iyi biliyor yavaşlığı,
çünkü yavaş bir iş yapıyoruz.
Çünkü bizim hızımıza toprak karar veriyor,
kalıntı karar veriyor kazı yaparken.
Biz karar vermiyoruz.
Bizim karar verdiğimiz tek şey oradaki,
istiyorsak fazla bir iş yapmak,
oradaki işçi sayısını arttırırız, zamanı
arttırırız, beş gün ise on beş gün yaparız
öyle bir iş çıkarmaya çalışırız ama asla
işin hızını arttıramayız çünkü insanın
doğasında, hayatın kendi
doğasında da bir hız var.
Hayat zaten söylüyor; güneş doğduğunda
uyanacaksın diyor, bak vaktinde de
uyuyacaksın diyor yani o kendi saatini
belirlemiş durumda, her şey belli.
Mevsimlerde seni belirliyor, bütün o döngü
içerisinde bir saat var zaten yani.
Biz onun için hep kendi
saatimizi yazıyoruz.
Barış, yine de barışabiliriz yani,
barış çünkü önemli bir şey.
Bu sükunet meselesini
burada slaytta izliyorsunuz.
Barışın yolu sükûnet gerçekten.
Ama sükûnetin yolu da barış.
Dünya'da bakın ki barış zamanlarına,
uygarlığın en ilerlediği,
en inanılmaz anıtların, muhteşem
görkemli şehirlerin ortaya konduğu
zamanlar yaşamış uygarlık tarihi.
"Pax Romana" Roma Barışı demek ve o dönem
yani birinci yüzyıl ve ikinci yüzyıl sonra
Anadolu da dâhil her tarafta en görkemli
şehirlerin, anıtların, binaların
olduğu bir dönem neden? Çünkü barış var.
Barış var. O bir sükûnet getiriyor
insanlara ve sanatla, kültürle,
şehirleriyle, insanlıklarıyla baş başa
kalıp onlarla uğraşacak
şansı buluyorlar kendilerinde.
Buna göre barış çok önemli bir şey.
Şimdi iyi zamanlarda yapılan şeyler
kendini zaten çok güzel gösteriyor.
Yavaş zamanlarda yapılan
özel şeyler oluyorlar.
Ne oluyor? Bu videoda gördüğünüz gibi
inanılmaz eserler çıkıyor.
Bu eserlerin hiç birisi; sanatçının,
Mikel Anj'ın ya da başka birisinin
çok hızlı çalışayım,
şunu bir an evvel yontayım da
iyi bir venus heykeli, Aphrodite demedi.
diyemez ki!
İyi bir eser çıkmaz ondan.
Nuh sükûneti içerisinde hiçbir saat
ve zaman kullanmaksızın
yavaşça işine organize olup, konsantre
olarak bir eser yaratması lazım onun,
onun hızla hiçbir ilişkisi olamaz zaten.
O nedenle yavaş yapılan
zamanlarda ürettiklerimizle,
hızlı zamanlarda yaptıklarımıza
bakarsak aslında tartabiliriz.
Ama bunu sonra ileride bir daha tartacağız
bakalım bu söylediğim doğru mu?
Bu, yavaş ve hız arasında, çelişkiler
dünyası esasısında biz yaşıyoruz.
Evet, peki hız güzel değil mi?
Hızlıyken güzel şeyler
yapmaz mıyız? Yaparız.
Bir Ferrari pilotuna, formuladaki
bir Ferrari pilotuna bakın.
O nasıl güzel bir şey yapıyor,
yarışıyor pistlerde.
İnanılmaz herkesi heyecana boğuyor
üstelik ve birinci de oluyor sonunda,
çıkıp da korkunç sevinerek
gösteriyor bunu.
Bu demek ki güzel bir şey.
İlla yavaşken güzel şeyleri
yapacak hâlimiz yok,
bazı şeylerde hızlı olarak yapılabilir.
İnsanın doğasına yavaş uygundur.
Biz nasıl yaratılışa göre
öne doğru programlaşırız.
Öne doğru yürüyeceğiz, bütün hücrelerimiz
önde bizim; bakan, gören, hissedip tadan,
dokular her şey önde duruyor falan.
Arkaya doğru yapılmamış,
mecbursan gidebilirsin ancak.
Yani bu, dolayısı ile geleceğe bakan
bir insan önündeki ileriye bakan
bir insan, yürümeye programlı
bir insan var, yürüyor.
Bu yürümek edebi yapılabilecek bir eylemya
yavaş çünkü ve sana ait bir şey,
Ama koşmak da var.
İyi de sen sürekli koşamazsın mesela,
o niye sana verilmiş o koşma özelliği
yaratıcı? O sen kendini kurtar,
hayatta kal diye vermiş.
Kaç? Başka bir özelliği yok.
Çünkü her hayvanın bir savunma
mekanizması var ama insanın yok.
Ancak kaçabilirsin ayaklarınla.
Ama bakın ki şu slayta, üst tarafta;
orada "Sirkus Maksimus",
iki yüz elli bin kişilik muhteşem bir
at yarış pisti, hipodrom...
Bugün bile yok benzeri, Roma döneminde
yapılmış Sirkus Marksimus,
aşağıda da bir formula pisti var.
Ama iyi bakın ki o yarışanları şu anda
siz görüyorsunuz, değil mi?
Tercihen hepiniz orada yarışanlara
bakıyorsunuz, hızlı giden arabalara,
atlara ve onları kullananlara bakıyorsunuz
ama hiçbiriniz arkada öyle oturan
ve onları izleyenlere
bakmadınız değil mi şimdi?
Şimdi bakın, orada oturan binlerce,
on binlerce insan var.
İki yüz elli bin kişi,
Sirkus Marksimus'da atları izliyor.
Onlar yavaş yaşayanlar, oturanlar ama
öbüleride hızlı yaşayıp gösteri yapanlar.
O oturanların hepsi onların yerinde olmak
üzere bakıyordur büyük bir ihtimalle.
-Ben de şu atı bir sürseydim yada
şu Ferrari ye binseydim,
diyorlardır içlerinden ama iyide herkes
zaten yapamaz bunu,
o zaman izlersiniz.
Buradaki şeyi de tartın, yavaş ve hızın;
başka anlardaki değerlendirmesini de
öyle yapabiliriz ama iyi de yavaş peki,
güzel zamanları çoğaltalım.
Bir Roma ailesinin, bir Larustika'daki
oturma odasında işte hanımların Lidya,
sağ alttaki Lidyalı hanımlar,
bizim buradan hanımlarımız.
Üstte de Roma'dan bir aile,
nasıl güzel zevk zamanları.
Roma Sins tabiyodan sonra öğlene kadar
çalış, öğleden sonra hiç bir çalışma yok.
O olağanüstü Roma hamamlarında,
ne öncesinde ne de sonrasında
kimse öyle yapmadı yani.
Yüz yirmi bin metrekare bir bina yapmış,
içinde her türlü eğlence,
rahatlama, dinlenme her şey var.
Varmoyu lüks bir hayat karşılamış ve
Roma akımını çok sevmiş.
Ve gittikleri yerlere de taşımışlar bunu.
O hamamları, özelindeki
Roma yaşama biçimini.
İşte size yavaş hayat...
Uzun saatlerce hamamda dinlen,
uzun saatlerce yemek ye,
hemen hızla bitirip gitme, sınırlan
sınavını yap orada falan, hayatını yaşa.
Keyif yap bunlar ama ölene kadar da
adam gibi çalışmayı da bekliyor,
yani çok iyi çalışmanı bekliyor.
Erkeklerde elbette bunu yapıyor
andronlarda, bu villalardaki
karşılama odalarında, misafir odalarında.
Onlar çok uzun eğlenme saatleri,
yeme içme saatleri, akşamları
öğleden sonraları yaşıyorlar,
yavaş yavaş yaşıyorlar, hiç acelesi
yok nasıl olsa bir gün ölecekler.
Bu en son Hatay'da bulunan mozaik
çok güzel söylüyor yani neşeli ol,
işte hayatını yaşa vesaire, bunun simgesel
bir hâli ve bunu iskeletle söylemesi
ne güzel değil mi?
Aslında korkunç görünüyor
ama çok sevimli.
Ya bunu unutmamak lazım herkes
böyle olacak hiç şansınız yok yani,
öyle bir kişi kalmayacak geriye.
Bütün etleriniz dökülecek hepsini
çıyanlar yiyecek toprağın altında,
kemik olacağız.
O güne kadar ne yaptınız yaptınız, ama
orada peki yine çelişki bakın size sundum.
O güne kadar ne yaptınız yaptınız da,
yavaş yavaş yaparsanız
bir sürü şey eksik kalacak.
Değil mi?
Bu da, bakın hatırlatıyorum sürekli
dengeyi değiştiriyorum.
O zaman hızlı yapacağız demek ki
bazı işlerimizi organize, planlı,
üretime yönelik,
hedefe odaklı yapacağız ki,
o işimizi adam gibi iyi yapıp, hızla
ve bir zaman kazanıp o zamanda da,
bu sefer insanca istediklerimizi
karşılayacak, keyifli yaşama
parçacıklarına ulaşalım diye.
Çünkü bir kazanç olaması lazım
ama işini bitiremezsen onu yapamazsın ki.
Gece olur ve eve gidersin.
Şimdi lanet laptoplar falan çıktı ya,
internette herkes home ofis çalışıyor.
Yani iş saatinden sonra işte
bırakamıyor kimse işini, eve,
bütün işler eve gidiyor ki
gece gündüz.
Şimdi bu böyle bir döngü
olamaz tabi insanca değil.
Aykırı yani durumumuza bir kere
aykırı ruh, kalmadı.
Şimdi o sağ alttaki resme bakın,
sağ alttaki adam ruhunu kaybetmiş.
Çarkların içinde koşturuyor koşturuyor
kravatı ile beraber yani bunun sonu yok.
Her şeyi birden hayatta güzel.
İşini çok iyi yapacaksın, bu memlekete,
millete, halka ne kadar borcun varsa,
ödemek üzere eşek gibi
çalışacaksın hakikaten.
Nitelikli, iyi, özgür, güzel
işler yapacaksın.
Ama bu arada kendini de unutmayacaksın ki
o işlerden daha fazla yapabilesin.
Çünkü ruhunu, keyfini, kalbini kaybetmiş
bir insan işini iyi yapamaz,
ondan iyi bir iş çıkmaz.
O zaman önce kendin kendini
mutlu etmen gerekir,
o boş zamanların dolacak, eğlence
zamanların, iş zamanların
hepsi olacak ve
o zaman hepsi iyi olacak.
Bildiğin bütün özellikler çalışacak.
İşte burada Aritotales'e bakın;
— Hayatın amacı mutluluktur diyor, Aristo.
Mutluluğun yönünü de sanat olarak
gösteriyor, evet sanattır.
Sanatla ilgili bütün o duygularınızı,
ilgilerinizi bir her şeyi silin;
bakalım ne kalıyor sizden geriye.
İnanın ki zeytin posası gibi bir şey
kalır, yağı çıkan zeytin posası gibi.
Sanat; bizi insanlaştıran sürecin
en önemli bir aracıdır.
Biz hep sanatçılara gıpta ederek yaşarız
ve öylede öleceğiz ama çok da üzülmeyiz.
Çünkü onların eserleri bizim
iyi yaşamamızı sağlar.
Biri heykeltıraş, biri sinema sanatçısı,
birisi başka bir şey falan...
Onlar hayata ve bize
sundukları güzelliklerle,
bizi insanlaştırma
sürecini hızlandıran insanlar.
O zaman, onlar da ama hızlı
çalışa çalışa bunları üretiyorlar.
Bizde hızla onları izlemek
üzere bir yoldayız.
Ama bakınca ki o relax hallerimiz
bizi insanlaştırıyor işte o zaman.
Yavaş hızlı, yavaş hızlı hep bakın iç içe.
Konuşmamın başından beri,
ayıramadım o yavaş ile hızlıyı bir tarafa.
Ben sabah hâlâ insanlardan
benden sonra yapıyor her zaman.
Erken uyanırım çünkü güneş doğduğunda
bana uyan demiş ki, yaratıcı demiş sen
bu güneş doğdu mu sende
uyanacaksın yani yeter artık.
Orada uyanıp bir mesai yaparız,
çalışırız daha kimseler uyanmadan.
Öğlene kadar âlâ âlâ yine çalışırız.
Sonra öğleden sonra
okulda işler falan üniversitede,
evet ama sonrada
hafta sonları akşamları
başka işler bu sefer yaparak onun
karşılığını vermeye çalışırız o yaşamanın.
Hem kendimize, hem borçlu olduğumuz
topluma karşılığını vermeye çalışırız.
Dikkat edin burada tabi bu biraz
sevimli olsun diye koymadım esasında,
dikkat çeksin diye koyduğum bir şey.
Bizim dışımızdaki doğadaki hiçbir canlı,
kendinden başka bir canlıya özenip
onun özelliklerine sahip olmak için
bir takım donanımlara donanmıyor,
donatmıyor kendini.
Bu bir tek bizim sorunumuz o da
akıldan gelen bir sorun;
akıl sorunu esasında var doğada.
Doğadan bizi uzaklaştıran aklımız zaten.
Bu iyi mi kötü mü? Çok da bilmiyorum,
yani esasında değerlendiremeyeceğim ama
böyle bir köpekte yok,
öyle bir başka bir hayvanda yok yani.
Bakın ki insan ama kendinden başka
her canlıda özelliği, her özelliği
kendine istiyor.
Ya bu kadar hırs olmaz ki;
yüzmekte istiyor, suyun altında balık gibi
gezmek de istiyor, uçmak da istiyor
ama zaten bu karada her şeyi yapıyor.
Yani bunların hepsini birden istiyor
insanoğlu, yapıyor da.
Şimdilerde yapıyor, ileride daha da iyi
yapacakmış başka bir şansımız yok.
İstenmeyecek gibi de değil yani
bir kuş gibi uçmak, bir balık gibi
suyun altlarında, Akdeniz'in dibinde
o bitkilere bakmak falan böyle.
Ne kadar cazip işler bunlar,
başka bir hayvan gibi de olmak.
Hayvan gibi olmak
o kadar önemli bir şey ki,
onlar çünkü hakikaten
çok dürüstte yaşıyorlar.
Biz artık birbirimize baktığımız zaman;
ulan bu hırsız mı acaba üç kağıtçı mı?
Bilmiyoruz.
Hayvanlar dosdoğru, dimdik yaşıyorlar
ve antik dönemdeki
tanrıları üreten insanlar,
o tanrılara kişilik atarken
hayvanlardan seçim yapmışlar.
Hanımefendi az önce
anlatıyordu baykuşu,
Athena'nın sembolüdür. Aklın, bilginin
sembolüdür, ışığın sembolüdür baykuş.
Athena, Atina'ya adını veren
tanrıçadır, akıl tanrıçası.
Zeus baş tanrıdır,
kartaldır onun ki mesela.
Ya niye bu hayvanlar, daha saymayacağım
ama bunlar o insan özellikleri olmayan,
insan üstü özellikleri
hayvanla gösteriyor,
tanrı işte bak yukarıdan
bakabiliyor diye.
Hayvanlar bunu denemiyorlar,
bizim yaptığımızı hayvanlar denemiyorlar.
Yani deneseler bu resimler
çıkacak bakın ne hâldeler.
Şu köpeğin hâline bakın,
böyle gözler fal taşı gibi.
Şimdi o köpek karada
yaşamak için yaratılmış,
amfibik de değil, hadi amfibik olsa
kurbağa gibi bir şey olsa
neyse, timsah gibi öyle de değil.
Yerini bilecek herkes yani,
yerini bilmedikçe biz bozuyoruz
her türlü dengeyi
ve şimdi ne kadar eksik
doğarsak, bizi sağaltan tıbbın
marifetleri nedeni ile ölemiyoruzda
yani bir ilimmasyon da yok,
ha bire çoğalıyoruz beş milyar,
on milyar, sekiz milyar insan olacak
ve bütün hayvanların her türlü
kaynağına biz sahip olacağız.
Onlar ne yapacaklar, bir gün hepimiz
kendi kendimizi de onları da yok edeceğiz.
Bir nehir bile yavaş akarken başka,
hızlı akarken farklıdır.
Bunu doğa bize çok güzel gösteriyor.
Bu Manavgat Nehri soldaki mesela,
sakince güzel güzel akarken etrafa
güzellik, dinginlik o masmavi hâli ile
her güzelliği veriyor, bereket de veriyor,
bozmuyor yıkmıyor bir tarafları.
Ama hızlı aktığında ne yapıyor,
işte bütün dünyalar her şey sular altında.
Ağaçlar sökülüyor,
ortalık birbirine batıyor,
doğa gücüyle intikam alıyor
belki ama orada da
doğal hız ve yavaşlığın
farkını, bize çok güzel gösteriyor.
Normalleşmek için çok uğraşabiliriz ama
bence sanki geç oldu bu, çok geç oldu.
Biz artık normalleşemeyeceğiz.
Yani bu saatten geriye gidemeyeceğiz.
Ben bu elbiseleri çıkarıp
ne yazık ki atamayacağım.
Bu ayakkabıları giymeye
devam edeceğim.
Hassabana'da araştırma
yapıyoruz bir yaz
ve orada dağda on beş gün,
hiç bir yer de yok, bir yerde doğada
çadırda kalacağız on beş gün.
Yirmi kişi ekip var öyle yapıyoruz.
Orada da bir baraka var,
bir teyze yaşıyor orada.
Altmış beş yetmiş yaşlarında,
ama ayakkabısız geziyor dağlarda.
Dağlarda her gün bizle, bizimkiler;
biz çok sportifiz, her gün dağa çıkıyoruz
falan yapıyorlar, en güzel
spor ayakkabılarla.
O teyze, o dağı; onların
günde bir kere çıktığı dağı,
günde on kere çıkıyor
keçileriyle beraber.
Ve ayağında ayakkabı yok.
Çocuklara dedim ki; çocuklar Fethiye'ye
gittiğinizde bir ayakkabı alın
teyzeye, bir şeyler yapalım falan
tamam aldık teşekkür etti,
aldı öptü bizi koydu rafa
ve biz oradan ayrılana kadar
o raftaydı ayakkabı.
Çünkü bu topuklar
bize lazım değil tanrı vermiş.
Bizim topuğumuzu normal kullansak
o aslında ayakkabı yani.
Topuk onun için öyledir
yani ayakkabıdır o.
Ama o teyzemiz ayakkabı
hâline gelmişti topuğu yani.
Hiç ne diken batıyor, ne bir şey oluyor
böyle seke seke yürüyordu yani.
Hiç gram yağ yok vücudunda falan.
Normal yaşıyordu yani ve yedikleri de
üç dört tane besin çeşidini geçmiyordu.
Biz şimdi daha felsefesini yapmaktayız.
Yavaş tarım, yavaş sıyı,
yavaş bilmem ne yavaş falan
yavaş gıda, slow food bilmem ne bunlar hep
yeni terimler gibi size gelebilir
ama esasında asıl insanın özünde o var
zaten slow oralar, slow yani.
Fast food mesela;
fast food da öyle bir şey
yani bunların hepsi
insanın eskisinde var.
Biz yine de keşfediyoruz moda geçiyor
bir daha keşfediyoruz falan ya şimdi.
Biz şimdi felsefesini yapmanın peşindeyiz,
avatar; avatar filmlerinde vesairede,
doğanın kendisini nasıl kollayacağını,
tanrının yer yüzündeki
görüntüleri ile beraber,
o doğal koruyan bir mücadele
içinde olduğumuzu,
filmlerle falan artık
anlatmaya çalışıyoruz.
Çocuklarımız bir sürü hayvan
bitkiyi ekranlardan tanımaya başlıyor.
Şimdi bakın bu ne kadar acıklı bir şey,
ben onu hissettim hazırlarken yani.
Duygularımız kalırsa bunları
konuşacağız diyorum.
Kederliyken, korkarken, beklerken,
sevinçliyken zaman farklı akar.
Birinde çok uzun, birinde çok kısa...
Bir türlü vakit geçmez bazen ama iyi de
onların hepsi insan duygusu.
Biz duygularımızı yitireceğiz hepsini
hiçbir şey kalmayacak ve belki de
bunları değerlendirmek için bile
artık çok geç olacak.
Benim bir şey dememe lüzum yok,
İnsan Hakları Evrensel Beyannamesi
24. Maddesi zaten bunu yasal olarak
söylüyor.
Diyor ki herkesin dinlenmeye,
eğlenmeye, çalışmaya,
ücretli izin yapmaya hakkı vardır diyor.
Bu 24. madde insan hakları
maddesi olarak vardır.
Eğer siz kendiniz beceremezseniz
kendinize tatil vermeyi,
eğer bizim hemşehrimiz
Dikkani gibi yapamazsanız,
o diyor ki vücutlarınızı onurlandırınız.
Onurlandıramazsanız vücutlarınızı o zaman,
İnsan Hakları Beyannamesi bunu yapacak.
Ben arkeoloğum, bunları da
ben kazdım onlar benim çizimlerim.
Haftalarca, aylarca, yer altında mezarlar.
İki bin yüz yıllık o ölenler...
İki bin yüz sonra buluştuk onlarla biz.
Toprakla deydi parmaklarımız birbirlerine.
Oradaki karı koca,
birbirlerine bakıyorlar.
Sahnelenmiş bir şekilde bakın
Hâlâ hayat devam ediyor ve
kafaların arasında oyun taşları yer alıyor
Bitmemiş hayat, biteceğine
inanmıyor ki o hayat devam edecek
ve onları ev gibi yapmış zaten,
öldükten sonra da birbirleri konuşup
hasbi hâl edecekler, oyun oynayacaklar.
Kendi kapları da
her şeyleri de onların yanında.
Yavaş olursak belki bir şeyleri
daha iyi yaşar mıyız?
Yada öbür dünyaya mı
bırakacağız bütün bunları?
Ulan ben karımla yavaş yaşayayım.
İyide o cehenneme giderse,
sen öbür tarafa gidersen ne olacak?
Nasıl olacak bu iş?
Zamanında oyununu oyna, iyi geçin,
barış içinde ol, güzellikler içinde ol.
Hoşluk yap, gülümse ya.
Gülümse yani.
Bu artık ağlamaktan yani insan
aslında ağlamaya da programlı değil.
Gülelim yani, bunun için de
yollar bulalım ama.
Yani memleketimizi mutlu edecek
şeyler yapalım ki, kendimizi koruyalım ki,
bağımsızlığımızı yitirmeyelim ki, gülelim.
Yoksa gülemeyiz de.
Biz yavaşlıktan bahsederken, yavaşlığa,
güzellemeler ve övgüler yazarken,
CERN'den haberler geliyor
ışık hızı aşıldı diyoruz.
Çaresiziz.
(Alkışlar)